hey guys i'm abby shart welcome to
Abby's kitchen I got a lot of great
feedback when it came to my egg cups
done five waves video and I know a lot
of you have asked me for some more
really great easy make-ahead
healthy breakfast on the go so today I
wanted to share with you one of my
favorites these are my sweet potato
bowls done three ways so these are vegan
they're gluten free so they're great for
a whole range of different dietary
restrictions not to mention that they
are so tasty and they pack the hunger
crushing combination of fiber protein
and healthy fats so let's do this I
[Music]
start by pricking some sweet potatoes
all over then placing them on a baking
sheet and baking them at 425 degrees for
about 45 to 50 minutes first up my fig
and tahini sweet potato Bowl I start by
cutting into my sweet potato and prying
it open adding a good cup of coconut
yogurt some figs pomegranate arils
pistachios a drizzle of tahini maple
syrup and some Zetas
enjoy next my PB&J sweet potato bowl
after I cut into my sweet potato I add
some grape chia jam peanuts coronation
grapes and some hemp parts don't forget
a big dollop of peanut butter and get in
there finally my tropical sweet potato
bowl to my sweet potato I add some diced
mango dragon fruit cashews cashew butter
and goji berries shredded coconut and
some coconut chips
enjoy
[Music]
so guys I hope you enjoyed my video for
my sweet potato bowls down three ways if
you did be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with some of
your favorite ways to top your sweet
potato Bowl subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]